fast jeder dritte deutsche leidet unter
chronischen schmerzen
viele probleme den die patienten
mitbringen sind eigentlich lösbar
man kriegt 1000 schmerzmedikamente alles
hilft nicht man hat trotzdem schmerzen
man ist einfach man fühlt sich machtlos
ich dachte ich bin verrückt im 300
seitigen ratgeber dem handbuch gegen den
schmerz erklärt bild autorin sarah
majorczyk zusammen mit 15 experten
welche arten von schmerz es gibt wie er
entsteht und vor allem was man tun kann
um ihn wieder loszuwerden das buch
informiert auf dem aktuellen stand des
wissens über die verschiedenen
schmerzerkrankungen das ganz besondere
ist aber dass patienten und patientinnen
zu wort kommen
assist gutgeschrieben gut verständlich
auch geschrieben und ich hoffe dass es
einfach einen großen leserkreis erreicht
[Musik]